foreign
years ago the Oslo Accords were signed
between Israel and the Palestine
Liberation Organization the agreements
were seen as a major turning point in
the conflict because it was the first
time that Israel and the PLO had
formally recognized one another this
image became iconic taken on the 13th of
September 1993. PLO chairman yasa Arafat
and Israel's then prime minister Yitzhak
Rabin shook hands on the White House law
and overseen by the then President Bill
Clinton Bill's law Accords were a series
of agreements signed between 1993 and
1999 that aimed to see Israel withdraw
from the territories it occupied during
the June 1967 war including the West
Bank East Jerusalem and Gaza and so most
Palestinians believed that the Accords
would create an independent Palestinian
state in the occupied territories
alongside Israel but that never happened
over the next three decades Israel
accelerated its expansion of illegal
settlements increased restrictions on
the movements of Palestinians within the
occupied territories and built a
separation wall as well as imposing a
Siege on the Gaza Strip through a Land
Air and Seed block Aid three decades on
the Oslo Accords are seen to have only
served to cement Israel's occupation
Laura Khan begins our coverage from the
occupied West Bank
I'm in the Palestinian town of Aram
behind me this eight meter high wall
extends for 712 kilometers cutting off
Palestine communities and isolating
occupied East Jerusalem Israel controls
both sides of that divide
here in the occupied West Bank
Palestinians are also separated by
Israeli roads illegal settlements and
checkpoints when the OZO agreement was
signed in 1993 this wall didn't exist
and neither did the checkpoints we don't
have continuous territorial you know a
landscape in order to think about
two-stage Solutions what we have on in
fact is one state in control but two
regimes it is apartheid
this is Ramallah it was supposed to be
the temporary seat for the Palestinian
Authority and it has signs that resemble
statehood everywhere
the Palestinian Community only sees the
negative effects of Oslo after 30 years
the Palestinian Authority failed to
establish a state Liberate the land or
build State institutions
in a recent poll 68 of Palestinians said
Oslo harmed their interests 71 said it
was wrong for the Palestine Liberation
Organization to sign the agreement
so less than five minutes from the
Palestinian president's headquarters is
the illegal Israeli settlement of betel
so this houses the Israeli civil
Administration which governs
Palestinians under occupation
two hours North is the city of Janine
which has become a major Flashpoint
I'm now in Janine refugee camp much of
which was destroyed in a two-day Israeli
assault in July drone strikes and
armored bulldozers leveled many of these
streets some Palestinians inside are
fighting the occupation so how do they
feel about their situation 30 years from
the Oslo agreement
the occupation rates wherever they want
and commit whatever crimes they want the
last assault was on Janine When They
carried out a massacre this is a
shameful agreement because what is taken
by force is only returned by force
so many Palestinians say they've been
left disillusioned as the promise of a
state slips further away
Laura Khan Al Jazeera the occupied West
Bank
is our correspondence in Bethlehem
overlooking the illegal Israeli
settlement of Homer neither it can be
said I think that even though it is an
anniversary no one's really celebrating
on the contrary people are reminded of
the era that they had some hope in 30
years ago that there could potentially
be a Palestinian state but now as we're
seeing it we're looking at the
manifestations of the Israeli occupation
and the basically the reason why there
wouldn't be a contiguous Palestinian
State this is the illegal settlement of
it houses only Israelis it was built on
Palestinian lands here in Bethlehem it
serves as an obstacle basically cutting
off and isolating occupied East
Jerusalem from occupied Bethlehem
basically you can see the facilities the
structures the buildings and let's not
forget that the lads here were
appropriated by the Israeli government
in the early 90s which is just two years
before the Oslo Accords were signed so
that tell tells you how much there were
Plans by the Israeli governments to keep
expanding illegal Israeli settlements
and we're talking now more about more
than 750
000 Israeli settlers residing illegally
in the occupied West Bank taking up
resources streets and most importantly
lands and the dreams of Palestinians to
have a state we've been talking to
Palestinians here in the occupied West
Bank and let's listen in to what they
had to say
this is a fully fledged occupation they
enter whichever City they want and do
whatever they want
if the world pressures Israel into a
peace process it will move forward
with Israel just bought time to solidify
the occupation
under the circumstances there's no way
for it to State
we're going for a confrontation if after
more than 70 years there wasn't peace
forget that it'll happen
there's no space left they didn't leave
us anything in Palestine they took all
the land
it says it would be what did you say a
Palestinian State what do you want me to
say where where if they raid every night
and take what they want
so there was nothing in the Oslo Accords
that committed Israel to stop the
illegal settlement expansion which is
why we're talking about a majority of
Palestinians 70 percent of them who
think that Oslo hurt the Palestinian
interest and that they believed that it
was wrong of the PLO to sign that
agreement Ibrahim in Bethlehem thank you